à propos justement de la série
d'attentats de l'organisation terroriste
al qaïda le 11 septembre dernier aux
états unis depuis quelques semaines des
informations courent selon lesquelles le
président george bush aurait été alerté
sans prendre les mesures de précaution
nécessaires
aujourd'hui c'est un agent du fbi à une
femme qui accuse sa hiérarchie de lui
avoir délibérément mis des bâtons dans
les roues avant le 11 septembre alors
qu'elle lui fournissait des indices sur
les risques d'attentats
dorothée dire qu elle est au service du
fbi depuis 21 ans et elle accuse
aujourd'hui sa hiérarchie son
réquisitoire fait douze pages
l'intégralité a été diffusé sur le site
internet du times il est accablant
coleen rowley avait dit elle fournit des
preuves dans la sphère acariès moussaoui
le français inculpé de complot
terroriste aux etats unis des indice qui
combinait avec un rapport précédent d'un
agent du fbi auraient dû éveiller des
soupçons sur des risques d'attentats
selon coline au volet le fbi à
washington n'aurait pas réagi refusant
même de lui accorder la possibilité de
fouiller l'ordinateur de moussavi selon
un spécialiste français le fbi aurait
sous-estimé le rôle de zacarias
moussaoui le fbi il savait qu'il avait
cette personne puisqu'il avait été
prévenu par le par les instructeurs et
les alliés du vieil le savez puisque la
dst avait été prévenue avait dit que
c'était un très gros poisson et le fbi
avait répondu à la dst écoutez si vous
type n'étant que ça on va vous l'envoyer
pour dire que quand même il n'avait pas
cru à la à la réalité de cette menace
cela fait déjà plusieurs semaines que
les vieilles et son directeur centre
d'une vive polémique pour avoir négligé
certaines pistes qui aurait pu limiter
l'ampleur de la tragédie du 11 septembre
fin juin une commission parlementaire
présidée par le sénateur démocrate bob
graham devrait entendre les directeurs
de la cia et du fbi haye mais les appels
sont de plus en plus nombreux en faveur
d'une commission indépendante
idée rejetée pour leur part le président
george bush